tv 78e glisse aujourd'hui dans la peau
d'un créateur d'entreprise nous avons
comme projet de monter un commerce
direction le ski cul pour notre premier
rendez vous et nous voilà arrivés au ski
cube c'est ici que nous avons notre
premier rendez vous dans notre étape de
création d'entreprise ici on va obtenir
des conseils et découvrir les
différentes étapes de la création de
notre projet suivez moi on y va
[Musique]
bienvenue qui cube
merci de m'accueillir donc comme convenu
comme je vous ai contacté j'ai un projet
d'ouvrir un commerce donc de créer une
entreprise et et je voulais avoir les
premiers renseignements les étapes
disons pour créer son entreprise
d'accord ok alors il ya quatre grandes
étapes dans la création d'entreprise
donc la première étape c'est
l'adéquation porteurs de projets projets
vous c'est à dire ça va permettre de
voir si votre projet est en cohérence
avec vos motivations votre personnalité
et la réglementation si on a eu la
deuxième étape c'est la partie étude de
marché donc là vous allez analyser la
clientèle la concurrence votre
environnement afin de voir si votre
activité allait potentiellement viable
ou pas la troisième étape ça va être la
partie financière
donc là on va monter un prévisionnel
financier notamment le plan de
financement voilà qu'est ce que vous
j'ai besoin pour démarrer mon activité
comme enjeu le finance et puis la partie
rentabilité le chiffre d'affaires que je
vais faire don combien je vais vendre de
t-shirts combien ils vont coûter
et puis bah qu'est ce que j'ai à payer
tous les mois mon loyer etc
donc ça nous permet de voir si le projet
est faisable d'un côté et rentable de
l'autre la quatrième étape c'est
l'aspect juridique
donc c'est de voir quel statut juridique
elle plus adaptée à votre projet or nous
savons que c'est un peu compliqué
aujourd'hui pour les créateurs
d'entreprises par rapport aux banques
notamment vous parlez de la deuxième
étape le financement comment nous
pouvons financer notre création
d'entreprise notre notre commerce pour
pour commencer notre activité bien sûr
donc il y existe différentes aides pour
pour augmenter vos fonds propres donc
par exemple ici on fait partie d'un
réseau qui s'appelle le réseau
initiative qui fait du prêt d'honneur
qui permet de compléter vos fonds
propres donc c'est un prêt d'honneur qui
peut aller de 5 à 25 mille euros et puis
derrière
généralement il ya les banques
classiquement qui complète et qui sont
là germans pour financer tout ce qui est
plutôt matériel investissement de
démarrage pour son activité maintenant
qu'on a la vision globale je me fais un
peu une idée sur les étapes qui
m'attendent qu'est ce que je fais dès
demain d'accord déjà dès demain va
falloir écrire votre projet donc qui
vous
être vos motivations et puis commencer à
regarder par rapport à votre projet ce
que vous souhaitez vendre s'il ya un
marché s'il ya une clientèle sur saint
quentin
si vous souhaitez vous installer en tout
cas sur saint quentin qui sont déjà les
concurrents qui est déjà installée pour
voir voilà comment vous allez vous
positionner par rapport à eux
et puis dans un deuxième temps vous
allez d'identifier comme ça si on est
sur un local gratien locale une zone de
chalandise donc peut-être un lieu ce
qu'on va s'installer en centre-ville
est-ce qu'on va s'installer au
e-commerce et du coup plus tôt peut-être
dans une pépinière d'entreprise voilà
selon les possibilités et je dirais
l'analyse de votre étude de marché vous
allez pouvoir identifier ce que vous
allez faire qui va permettre derrière de
déboucher sur les premières prévisions
financières de votre projet je sais que
vous êtes ma ma porte d'entrée le ski
cube sera la porte d'entrée pour la
création de mon entreprise
est-ce que je peux m'adresser à d'autres
acteurs bien sûr donc au sein du ski
tube on a un réseau de partenaires qui
vient régulièrement donc notamment dans
le cadre du réseau entrepreneurs hashtag
leader porté par la région
on a une possibilité en phase 1 de se
faire accompagner pour le montage du
business plan notamment donc sur les
quatre étapes que je vous ai cités c'est
la chambre de commerce la chambre de
métiers et le réseau bg e
voilà qui sont les trois acteurs du
territoire intervenir bon je pense que
j'ai suffisamment d'informations pour ce
premier rendez vous en tout cas on peut
prévoir peut-être un autre entretien on
pourra placer 1 qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire à ce moment-là barreaux pour avoir
partout moment où vous aurez commencé à
écrire votre projet on va pouvoir
avancer et puis voir au fur et à mesure
un peu un plan d'étape un plan d'action
sur les études de marché ou est-ce que
vous en êtes avancé sur le prévisionnel
ou pas au pao pao fonction de votre
avancement céline euros merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup merci pour votre accueil
de rien je vais vous raccompagner merci
[Musique]
et pour toute information sur la
création d'entreprise vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site du ski cube qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran